BMI stands for business model
innovation.
Innovation is often thought to be doing
something new,
but mostly doing something new.
By developing a new technology,
finding a new market or,
or designing a product to better match
consumer needs.
Business model innovation is a different
kind of innovation.
This is where you produce basically the
same product address,
the same market needs.
But the way in which you provision this
product to the market involves a new
business model.
This could be a new revenue model,
this could be a new cost model or most
interestingly it could be in different
risk model.
All of these models might help you
disrupt incumbents,
change the way things are done in an,
in an industry and provide a superior
product,
superior services and,
and disrupt the game in the industry.
So first off,
I think,
um,
uh,
BMI as an approach,
is not,
not only about mitigating risk,
it is more about managing risk.
So we often think risk is a bad thing.
We got to a risk is going to hurt our
business.
Risk is,
is,
is always a bad thing.
Turns out companies that can better
manage risk companies that can
differentiate themselves from the
incumbents in how their business model
deals with the risk might have a
significant advantage over the
incumbents over the folks who don't do
that.
So we can think of,
um,
in the,
in the transportation industry,
a company like Uber,
which is this transportation network
provider company,
the taxi hailing app,
some [inaudible],
some of you might know a,
compare that to a traditional taxi
service provider or a black car,
a service provider.
Now Black car service provider has,
has a much more risk in its business
model because it has to invest in,
in,
in a heavy asset load before any,
any demand shows up come through.
Like Uber on the other hand has a
business model which has a lot,
lot lower risks because it's the cost
and revenue scale up together.
If a lot of people want born taxi rides,
Uber ends up,
uh,
bringing in a lot of drivers on board.
If nobody wants a taxi ride,
there are no traffic drivers who are
paid.
And that that business model manages the
demand risk in a lot superior fashion
than a traditional taxi model does.
And that allows it to differentiate
itself from the traditional model and,
and provide a superior service to
consumers,
basically a service which allows them to
almost guarantee,
um,
a car within a few minutes,
irrespective of where,
where they are or irrespective of the
time of the day.
So that's,
that's using risk to differentiate
yourself not only as something you have
we have to worry about or tried to
mitigate.
Okay.